[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour le 7 8 c'est votre émission
d'actualité sur TV 78 nous sommes le
lundi 2 octobre voici les titres et deux
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie dans
les Yvelines elles font partie des 238
nouvelles qui vont s'implanter sur le
territoire français d'ici 2027 Emmanuel
Macron a dévoilé la liste cet après-midi
à l'occasion d'un déplacement dans le
Lot-et-Garonne l'une de ces brigades
sera fixée déployée à Ben l'autre sera
mobile et implanté à Rambouillet et
démystifier un univers parfois obscur
mais au combien important dans notre
quotidien le sprint Kamp qui s'est tenu
à Élancourt avait pour but d'initier au
métier du digital pendant 10 jours les
participants ont été formés à la
création de sites internet ou encore à
la cybersécurité retour d'expérience
dans cette édition
c'est un début de saison parfait pour le
plaisir Rugby Club les Yvelinois
comptent trois victoires en autant de
match dans le championnat de fédéral 2
où ils sont en tête hier le PRC n'a fait
qu'une bouchée d'Anthony dans la
troisième journée score final 43 à 10 le
résumé de la rencontre à suivre
et puis l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième
partie d'émission ne reviendrons sur la
pause symbolique de la première pierre
du centre de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
c'était ce matin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux dans un an la
ville accueillera Agora le premier
village 100% inclusif nous avons
rencontré Jean Gon le président de cette
fédération de cette fondation créée en
1945 par Yvonne et Charles de Gaulle
et je suis accompagné pour cette édition
du 7 8 de Michael el nidoro bonsoir de
la rédaction de TV 78 alors vous êtes
bien installé sur notre nouveau plateau
il est magnifique on s'y sent bien et
j'espère que l'émission va bien se
dérouler on l'espère alors le plateau
vous avez reconnu sans doute la table
mais maintenant derrière il y a une
petite partie salon ou dans quelques
jours on l'espère on pourra recevoir nos
invités on va vous proposer également
des des chroniques avec un écran qui
sera installé on prend peu à peu nos
marques on s'installe petit à petit sur
ce nouveau plateau de TV 78 mais la
formule reste toujours la même de
l'actualité des infos pratiques des
idées de sortie à distiller dans cette
édition du 7 août alors dans quelques
instants Michael avec vous on va faire
le point sur l'actualité à retenir de ce
lundi dans les Yvelines où on parlez
aussi de sport de quoi s'agira-t-il ce
soir alors on va parler de
l'entraînement qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui
à du Pays de Galles Pays de Galles qui
est engagé dans cette Coupe du monde de
rugby 2023 il y avait environ 1000
personnes autour du terrain pour
encourager les Gallois dans la suite de
la compétition on parlera aussi de
plaisir vous l'avez dit un plaisir qui a
EMP sont troisième match en fédéral de
3e match sur 3 on parlera également de
football avec la Coupe de France et le
quatrième tour de cette magnifique
compétition qui est la Coupe de France
il y aura un mot aussi tout à l'heure de
météo puisque en ce moment il fait très
chaud dans les Yvelines et dans le reste
de la France de la France il y a un état
indien qui se poursuit tout ça ce sera
dans quelques instants sur TV 78
[Musique]
mais d'abord nickel ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité du jour dans le
département et pour commencer
livrelinois Gérard Larcher a été réélu à
la présidence du Sénat aucune surprise
puisque la droite avait conservé la
majorité à la Chambre haute après les
élections sénatoriales du 24 septembre
Gérard Larcher obtenu cet après-midi 218
voies sur 348 votants il remplit donc
pour un cinquième mandat de président
postes que l'ancien maire de Rambouillet
occupé de 2008 à 2011 et depuis 2014 je
le disais dans les titres bientôt deux
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie dans
les Yvelines elles font partie des 238
nouvelles brigades qui vont être déprées
d'ici 2027 sur le territoire français
annonce cet après-midi d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de son déplacement à Tonneins dans
le Lot-et-Garonne l'une de ses brigades
divinois sera fixe et implantée dans la
commune de Beynes l'autre sera mobile
est basé à Rambouillet selon l'Élysée le
but est je cite de répondre à la hausse
de la délinquance en milieu rural et de
renforcer le lien entre les populations
et les forces de l'ordre 3 mois après
les émeutes le premier village 100%
exclusive de France s'implante dans les
Yvelines et c'est à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce matin lundi à
2 octobre avait lieu la pose symbolique
de la première pierre par la Fondation
Anne De Gaulle c'était en présence
d'Aurore berger ministre des Solidarités
et des familles et de Fadila à katabi à
ministre délégation des personnes
handicapées pendant longtemps on n'a pas
voulu voir les personnes en situation de
handicap pendant longtemps on a préféré
presque les parquets dans des
établissements qui étaient dédiés mais
qui étaient éloignés au centre-ville de
nos centres bourg là l'objet même de cet
établissement c'est justement de ne pas
en être un d'être un village d'être un
village qui doit pouvoir accueillir tout
le monde c'est à dire des personnes qui
ne sont pas en situation de handicap qui
vont pouvoir y circuler qui vont pouvoir
côtoyer tout simplement d'autres
Français sans faire mention de ce
handicap et ça je crois que c'est une
avancée magnifique c'est toute
l'innovation qui est mise ici au service
des personnes en situation de handicap
il va y avoir un campus recherche donc
très beau projet un projet en fait très
global qui à la fois bon il y a le les
professionnels du médico-social mais
également toute la partie recherche pour
pouvoir encore améliorer et apporter les
réponses les plus adéquates les plus
j'allais dire responsables et qui
répondent au plus près des personnes en
situation de handicap baptiser Agora le
village est situé avenue du parc en face
de la déchetterie les détails de ce
projet en seconde partie d'émission avec
l'invité du 7 8 janvan droule au
président de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
alors autre ministre en visite dans les
Yvelines c'est Jean-Noël barreau le
ministre délégué en charge du numérique
à assister à l'inauguration du nouveau à
data center télé house s'installer à
Magny-les-Hameaux ainsi de plus de 10000
mètres carrés consacrés au stockage de
données nous reviendrons sur cette
information demain dans le 7 8 la 7e
édition du salon economie job c'est
demain le rendez-vous se tient au Pôle
Universitaire Léonard de Vinci à
Courbevoie dans les Hauts-de-Seine plus
de 40 exposants seront sur place pour
faire découvrir les métiers du
médico-social et de la petite enfance
vous pourrez aussi découvrir différentes
formations du secteur et les emplois
disponibles au programme également cette
année un escape game découverte des
métiers le kit de simulation du
vieillissement un atelier coaching mais
aussi un job dating sur les métiers du
secteur pour terminer Michael depuis
aujourd'hui c'est le coup d'envoi de la
nouvelle campagne de vaccination contre
le covid-19 elle est ouverte à tous et
sans âges minimum vous pouvez dès
aujourd'hui vous faire vacciner chez
votre médecin ou à la pharmacie il
s'agit de vaccins ciblant le sous
variant domicron xbb 1.5 devenu
majoritaire toujours sans obligation
cette vaccination reste fortement
conseillée pour les personnes les plus à
risque une vaccination toujours prise en
charge à 100% par l'Assurance Maladie
pour l'ensemble de la population pour
recevoir cette dose de rappel vous devez
attendre au moins 6 mois depuis votre
dernière injection contre le covid-19
merci Michael et si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous fait
réagir près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
dans l'actualité également une formation
pour s'exercer au métier du digital
durant des jours un sprint camp était
proposé au campus numérique à Élancourt
création d'un site internet ou
initiation à la cybersécurité une
trentaine de participants a pu mettre en
place ces différents projets pour gagner
de nouvelles compétences numériques
reportage de Julien le Leroy
elle est parfaite et ben en fait j'ai
fait aligné à gauche du coup on fait ça
déformé le texte en fait
démystifier un univers parfois obscur
c'est l'objectif du sprint camp organisé
au campus numérique à Élancourt le
concept s'initie à 5 professions du
digital gratuitement durant 10 jours la
trentaine de participants sa cantinois a
pu découvrir les métiers de développeur
cybersécurité community manager
webdesigner pour ces personnes parfois
éloignées du monde du travail pas de
pré-requis seulement la motivation
d'apprendre c'est vraiment la première
étape vers
retourner en formation après enfin ou
retourner à l'emploi mais c'est juste
remettre le pied à l'étrier
développer des nouveaux des nouvelles
compétences ou se sentir en confiance
avec les compétences qu'on possède on le
voit il y en a pour certains qui
savaient tout juste allumer un
ordinateur et qui et qui ressortent de
la dent avec au moins des cordes en plus
et des envies supplémentaires de se dire
aussi qu'on peut tout simplement y
arriver comment une formation de
graphiste café China 28 ans a décidé
d'intégrer le sprin camp pour acquérir
de nouvelles connaissances numériques en
trois jours elle a créé sa propre page
internet sur Wix avec l'aide de sa
formatrice Sandra je me lance en
freelance on peut faire des chattes
graphiques vraiment me spécialiser dans
la chatte graphique et tout donc
éventuellement aussi faire des sites Web
ou des gens habituellement qu'on ne
connaît pas quelque chose et qu'on en
fasse une grande personne qu'on est de
quelqu’un quand on est déjà adulte on a
du mal à poser des questions mais
c'était vraiment comme des discussions
et ça passait crâne ils ont une manière
en fait de t'apprendre sans te rendre
stupide animation en Javascript ou
création graphique sur l'application
canva le dernier jour de formation s'est
conclu le 29 septembre par une
présentation des différents projets
entre les apprenants une occasion de
gagner en confiance grâce à de nouvelles
compétences personnelles
[Musique]
si je vous dis l'acronyme Kaf Michael ça
vous fait penser à quoi CAF
Caisse d'Assurance familiale c'est ça
qui recrute et propose une grande
diversité de métiers demain mardi elle a
cave des Yvelines organisent son premier
forum des métiers dans ces locaux à
Versailles c'est de 9h à 14h tous ceux
qu'il faut savoir sur ce rendez-vous
avec Lisa Shore qui est responsable des
ressources humaines à la cape des
Yvelines elle a été interrogée par
Régine ralech
[Musique]
la sécurité sociale lance la première
édition de la Semaine de l'emploi à la
sécu cette semaine du 2 au 6 octobre et
à la cave des Yvelines nous avons fait
le choix d'organiser un forum des
métiers demain mardi 3 octobre de 9h à
14h ici à Versailles objectif est double
pour nous c'est de faire découvrir la
pluralité de nos métiers au plus grand
nombre et également de répondre à un
enjeu de recrutement qui est fort
[Musique]
nous avons une pluralité de métiers à
l'acadés Yvelines lors du forum nous
allons présenter cinq grandes familles
de métiers donc les métiers des
prestations et de la relation de service
aux allocataires les métiers de la
relation de service aux familles et aux
partenaires les métiers de la sécurité
de la sécurité financière les métiers de
la gestion interne donc des fonctions
support et aussi les métiers du
management
[Musique]
au-delà des diplômes nous ce qu'on va
rechercher ce sont des compétences c'est
aussi une motivation une capacité
d'évolution nous formons aussi nos
collaborateurs n'ont vraiment nous
recherchons des profils très diversifiés
y compris nous recrutons des alternants
et des jeunes diplômés
lors de la matinée les participants
pourront venir rencontrer des
collaborateurs de la cave des Yvelines
pour échanger sur leur expérience leur
vécu ils pourront également rencontrer
l'équipe RH sur le process de
recrutement et pourquoi pas déposer leur
CV
[Musique]
pour s'inscrire à ce forum c'est très
simple il suffit d'aller sur le site
caf.fr à la rubrique ma Caf
l'inscription n'est pas obligatoire mais
elle est recommandée pour une meilleure
organisation du forum puisque lorsque
vous vous inscrivez vous pouvez
également choisir le créneau souhaité
donc soit de 9h à 11h de 11h à 12h30 ou
de 12h30 à 14h
[Musique]
les élus de 50 ans divine ont fait leur
rentrée un premier conseil
d'agglomération après la pause estivale
s'est tenue la semaine dernière avec une
trentaine de délibérations à l'ordre du
jour les trois choses à retenir avec
Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
l'enveloppe c'est une enveloppe qui
contient la totalité des travaux à la
fois les aménagements prioritaires et
préalable pour l'épreuve elle-même des
Jeux Olympiques les épreuves masculines
et féminines devaient VTT et elle
comprennent également la partie héritage
[Musique]
malgré les conditions économiques
extrêmement difficiles ont fait tout
pour que la culture garde une place de
choix on est convaincu à 50 ans divine
que la culture fait partie non seulement
du rayonnement d'un territoire mais
aussi de son attractivité et contribue à
la cohésion et au vivre ensemble
l'actualité sportive des Yvelines c'est
tout de suite dans le 7 8
[Musique]
Michael toujours bien sûr installé avec
moi en plateau et en cette période de
coupe du monde on débute par du rugby on
va prendre la direction de Versailles le
Pays de Galles s'est entraîné
aujourd'hui sur la pelouse du Rubik club
de Versailles au stade montbonron dans
le cadre de la Coupe du Monde c'est le
stade Porsche montagne pardon
excusez-moi je me suis je me suis trompé
plus de Miss spectateurs se sont
déplacés pour voir le 15 du poireau en
action et de nombreux supporters n'ont
pas hésité à s'habiller en rouge on
écoute les différentes réactions autour
du terrain c'est l'occasion de voir un
entraînement de rugby donc c'est
bien c'est juste à côté de chez nous
surtout donc on a une chance aujourd'hui
de pouvoir aller voir s'entraîner et
puis leur rendre hommage et honneur en
fait on est en présence autour du stade
le Pays de Galles a pour quand de base
la ville royale de Versailles pendant
toute la durée de la compétition alors
j'ai voulu vous faire plaisir pour cette
grande première à Grégory je vous ai
apporté un petit drapeau c'est vraiment
gentil ils ont distribué merci d'avoir
pensé à moi nickel d'ailleurs on voit
bien sur le drapeau gallois qui a du
vert c'est pour ça qu'on les a vu en
verre parce que les galons on a
l'habitude quand même de les voir en
rouge exactement vous avez raison
n'hésitez pas à le mettre la rédaction
sur votre bureau on supporte bien sûr
aussi l'équipe de France c'est pour ça
qu'il y a le petit drapeau de l'équipe
de le drapeau du pays de Galles
effectivement accueilli du côté de
Versailles on va continuer avec du rugby
cette fois-ci la Fédérale de le
championnat alors dans le choc qui
opposé le premier au deuxième de la
poule 8 le plaisir Rugby Club c'est
imposé sur son terrain face à Anthony
sur le score de 43 à 10 le résumé du
match des images de Julien Leroy
un choc pour cette troisième journée de
Fédérale 2 le leader plaisir recevait au
stade Robert Barran les deuxièmes du
classement Anthony sous le soleil les
joueurs locaux ont brillé ce dimanche
premier octobre dominateur il s'impose
assez facilement sur leur terrain sur le
score de 43 à 10
on a fait une bonne interne on a su
marquer tout de suite ensuite c'était un
peu dur en revenant de la mi-temps mais
on a réussi à reprendre en main à les
vendre dernière minute et on a réussi à
les chercher le bonus donc c'est bien ce
qui me satisfait c'est en premier c'est
l'engagement des mecs ils ont vraiment
tout donné aujourd'hui du du 1 au 22
donc ça c'est très très bien très bel
état d'esprit ça nous tenait à coeur de
de valider encore une fois ce bloc à la
maison avec cette victoire plaisir
s'envole en tête du classement de la
poule 8 de Fédérale 2 les plaisirsois
sont leader avec 5 points d'avant sur le
deuxième Saint-Malo des résultats qui
permettent au club de nourrir de grandes
ambitions pour cette saison 2023 2024 le
championnat je pense qu'on va jouer les
premières places nous c'est l'objectif
de toute façon de de se qualifier en
barrage direct fin de ce qualifiant
facile à directement enfin bref c'est
pas les barrages donc là c'est bien on
valide et on espère que ça va être comme
ça toute l'année on est on est serein je
veux dire on est serein on est on est on
n'est pas en surconscience on sait on
sait où on en est on sait où on veut
aller voilà donc on se donne les moyens
de faire les choses et encore une fois
je félicite les joueurs parce que c'est
eux qui font le boulot aux entraînements
le boulot en match prochain match pour
plaisir le dimanche 15 octobre les
Yvelines se déplaceront sur la pelouse
de Plouzané neuvième du classement
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné
[Musique]
oui il y avait l'ambiance
on espère que ça va continuer ça devrait
continuer normalement alors toujours en
Fédérale 2 dans la même poule que
plaisir Versailles s'est imposé dans la
douleur à l'extérieur face au MLS GP le
score 32 à 26 au classement Versailles
et 6e avec un bilan de deux victoires
une défaite de son côté le mlgp et 11e
avec trois défaites au compteur on va
maintenant parler de football en jouet
ce week-end le quatrième tour de la
Coupe de France une compétition qui
passionne toujours autant le public
parmi les principaux résultats des clubs
yvelinois nos FLE s'impose sur le
terrain à des clés Souilly quatre tirs
au but à 1 Feucherolles perd 4 à 0 à
domicile contre Plessis-Robinson
Maisons-Laffitte perd 5 à 2 à domicile
contre noiséenne trap sort également de
la Coupe de France en perdant 3-0 face
au Racing Club de France où il gagne 4 à
0 sur la pelouse de Courcouronnes et
châteaux remporte le match 100% Vinois
contre Andrésy 10 à 1 les rencontres du
cinquième tour auront lieu les 14 et 15
octobre comme d'habitude on espère qu'il
y aura un petit poucet yvelinois à
l'image de Versailles comme il y a deux
saisons les demi-finales de la Coupe de
France et qui avait perdu contre Nice
c'était historique pour un club
yvelinois dans vos résultats sportifs on
parle aussi dans le bal féminin dans le
championnat de National 2
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est imposé 33 à
21 ce samedi soir face à l'équipe de
Tessy club handball une victoire à
domicile qui fait du bien au classement
les immigrantaines sont à la quatrième
place de la poule à trois points du
premier Rosière Saint Julien on termine
par du tennis notre évier noir Arthur
Riner n'a pas réussi à remporter l'ATP
250 d'asta Nice c'est incliné 7 6 6 2 en
1h55 contre le français Adrian Mannarino
34e mondiale combattif il n'a pas réussi
à emporter les moments clés le
saint-germain-nois sera Masters de
Shanghai ce mercredi à 4 octobre il
jouera en 64e de finale contre le
Hongrois Fabian à morosan merci Michael
et on vous retrouve bien sûr lundi
prochain pour de nouveaux résultats
sportifs dans le 7 8 ce serait là vous
serez là c'est l'heure à présent de la
météo
et vous l'avez constaté je le sais que
c'est votre cas nickel qu'il fait encore
très chaud il a fait très chaud
aujourd'hui dans le département des
Yvelines en ce lundi deux octobre le
thermomètre qui a grimpé jusqu'à 28
degrés cet après-midi des températures
inédites pour un début d'automne dans
les Yvelines elles seront de nouveau
élevées en fin de semaine vos conseils
c'est vrai qu'on rédaction on a beaucoup
vu cet après-midi on a aussi la chance
d'avoir un peu de climatisation et donc
ça ça fait du bien en ces périodes de
chaleur rougir aussi du côté de
Versailles aujourd'hui avec les fortes
chaleurs mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est inhabituel en ce mois d'octobre
d'avoir des températures de
aussi élevé des températures estivales
alors avant cela demain avant la fin de
semaine où je vous le disais les
températures vont remonter c'est le
retour de la pluie en attendant demain
qui va amener un peu de fraîcheur dans
le département le matin comptait 18
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 17 degrés sur
le reste du territoire éblinois demain
après-midi pas de pluie mais des
éclaircies fera
17 à 19 degrés dans le département et ce
mardi 3 octobre nous fêterons les Gérard
seller de l'invité du 7 8
nous sommes avec jambon Droux le
président de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
bonjour aujourd'hui une pierre
symbolique a été posée la Fondation
s'installe à Montigny déjà
Montigny-le-Bretonneux pourquoi alors
au-delà de la première pierre vous
l'avez bien compris c'est vraiment le
lancement d'un mouvement 100% inclusif
pourquoi Montigny bah écoutez parce que
en fait l'occasion s'est présentée
d'acquérir une très grande percelle en
pleine ville et dans un environnement
qui reste très apaisant très
accompagnant avec ses arbres cette
verdure et pour nous c'était vraiment le
premier défi qu'on a dû relever vous
pensez bien que c'est compliqué dans une
agglomération comme Saint-Quentin de
trouver une telle superficie et là je
veux saluer naturellement l'aide des
services de l'État et du préfet
Jean-Jacques Brou en particulier qui a
eu un rôle déterminant avec le maire
Laurent mercart donc effectivement vous
l'écosystème est absolument exceptionnel
puisque comme vous l'avez compris
également un des grand s messages et
celui de l'innovation de solutions
nouvelles d'accompagnement mais pas que
une fondation qui devient également un
espace de recherche et d'enseignement à
côté de cette plateforme d'hébergement
et pour ça
peut-on rêver mieux sur notre territoire
que la communauté de Saint-Quentin avec
la faculté de Saint-Quentin à quelques
encablures le plateau de Saclay tout le
mari tout le maillage territorial et
économique scientifique du territoire
qui est tout à fait exceptionnel en
Île-de-France et dans notre pays on
parle d'un village inclusif on va y
retrouver de toutes tout le monde sera
accueilli sur le terrain pendant trop
longtemps
l'accueil et l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap en
institution se faisait de façon
relativement cloisonnée et
compartimentée
bien sûr que des structures comme celle
là doivent exister et doivent se
développer parce que certaines personnes
ont besoin d'un environnement
extrêmement sécurisé mais dans l'immense
majorité des cas il faut tout faire
encore une fois pour que chaque personne
en situation de handicap soit un citoyen
comme les autres et puis se faire valoir
son droit à l'autodér en particulier de
choisir là où ils veulent vivre et
comment ils veulent vivre et précisément
ce village qui est ouvert vers la ville
va permettre de leur proposer la
solution adaptée à leurs besoins leur
permettre de déambuler à l'intérieur du
village mais également dans la commune
avoir accès aux activités de loisirs aux
activités culturelles bref de vivre
comme tout à chacun mais pour que ça
marche pour que ça marche il faut que
les personnes qui le vont rencontrer sur
leur chemin soit en capacité de
communiquer avec elle et c'est tout
l'idée justement
d'accompagner la société à devenir
accompagnante en leur donnant chaque
citoyen des clés de communication très
simple mais qui nous permettent à toutes
et tous de rentrer en relation avec ces
personnes tous les handicaps seront pris
en charge vous êtes sur du trouble
cognitif trisomie 21 le public qui est
hébergé dans nos dans nos structures
sont des personnes présentant une
déficience intellectuelle et ce qu'on
appelle un trouble du
neuro-développement qui comprend un
éventail très large de troubles de
déficience intellectuelle dont les
troubles du spectre autistique
mais effectivement notre notre cœur de
métier je dirais et d'expertise c'est
les troubles du neurodéveloppement et la
déficience intellectuelle alors vous
l'avez dit très vite puisqu'il y aura un
laboratoire si vous l'avez pensé en
quatre maisons
alors il y a effectivement quatre
maisonnées d'habitants
d'habitants j'insiste sur le terme
d'habitat parce que vraiment c'est
vraiment le cœur du projet que ces
personnes se sentent comme chez elle et
puis deux autres maisonnées que nous
autorise la réserve foncière de notre
terrain d'ailleurs permis de construire
doit être déposé dans les tous prochains
jours donc l'un des bâtiments à vocation
à accueillir le premier campus recherche
dédié à 100% à l'inclusion
et à l'accompagnement de l'ensemble de
notre territoire ville dans un premier
temps mais au-delà naturellement ce
projet à vocation à se répliquer partout
en France voilà pour rendre la société
accompagnante et permettre partout
partout à tout moment la rencontre
accompagnée leur donner une certaine
autonomie finalement au cœur de la
société peut-être oui le faire valoir
leurs droits tout simplement je crois
que l'enjeu il est là la ministre l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure faire valoir
leurs droits et le premier de ses droits
c'est de être en capacité d'habiter de
se déplacer et de communiquer avec les
autres tout simplement on le voit le
chantier bien avancé on va devoir vous
libérer d'ailleurs un calendrier pour la
fin de ces travaux nous on absolument le
le calendrier tel qu'il avait été fixé
l'ouverture est prévu dans un an en
septembre 2024
merci beaucoup je vous
voilà c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité rendez-vous dès demain pour une
nouvelle édition ce sera avec Mathilde
Franco belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]